Uh, let's see. Where do we want to go next?
Why don't we talk to, let's talk to Sam. We
haven't heard from Sam for a while. Uh, what's
going on? Sam? What's new with you?
Hi. Uh, hi. Can you hear me?
We can, although I have a few guesses as to
maybe some of the different things going on
with your connection. A, I can't tell what
it is, but what, what's going on? Say Hi
David. Can you hear me now? Yes, I can. Hi
David. I have a question with a gyre bull
snarl. As a foreign leader, he might, uh,
be a lot of words. I can't say on the air,
but do you think it's worth, um, trading with
him as a foreign leader because he wants to
be more friendly with the United States? How
do you feel about that?
Do you mean trading Trump for Balsa narrow
or do you mean just the u s engaging in trade
with Brazil,
open up free trade agreements, free trade
agreements and what not. He wants to be friendlier
with the United States than Lula. The previous
president.
Yeah, I, I have no problem. Again, so listen,
this is a big thing that now a lot of right
wingers are jumping on, which is we should
want a brute be friendly with everybody. Let's
be friendly with Putin. Let's be friendly
with Kim Jong going and all of that. That's
totally fine. The problem isn't friendliness.
The problem is when our president just gets
himself taken advantage of and he doesn't
even realize it because he's so ignorant,
which is I think what's happening with Putin
and what's happening with Kim Jong Un. So
I have no like a priori opposition to getting
more involved economically with Brazil, assuming
that it's being done in a way that you know,
to call something mutually beneficial. If
you have a zero sum view on a lot of these
issues, that something can't be mutually beneficial.
The problem is I just don't trust Trump to
not get himself taken advantage of and not
even realize it, which is the theme. Hello?
Hello?
Yeah.
All right. Sam's gone weird. Um, okay. Sam,
Walt, great to hear from you. I'll be at briefly,